Do the Byrdes make it back to Chicago?
What will happen to Ruth's fortune?
Will Three get his revenge for his family?
Keep watching, because these are the questions
we still need answers to after the "Ozark"
finale.
For a while, Ruth claims victory over the
Byrdes by taking control of the casino.
She receives the rights that belonged to Darlene
Snell, as well as the family farm.
"Seeing as it's Darlene's land, only feels
right for it to be run by locals."
It even looks like she might get away with
killing Javi.
But alas, Camila bullies Clare into telling
her who killed her son.
Soon enough, Camila ambushes Ruth outside
her home, and the cartel boss shoots the fiery
fan favorite in the final hour.
This death introduces a major question: What
will happen to Ruth's possessions, such as
her stake in the casino, the Snell farm, and
the Lazy-O Motel?
Though this might not seem substantial in
the grand scheme of things, the cartel has
used the casino to launder money, despite
Ruth and Rachel Garrison's desire to go clean.
It seems likely that Three Langmore will gain
the rights to Ruth's possessions unless she's
listed Rachel as a benefactor.
But all of this is based on speculation.
Ruth was, to say the least, wealthy before
her demise.
The show makes a point of spotlighting this,
given where she's from and the fact that her
record is officially clean before her death.
All of that money has got to go somewhere.
Ruth convinces Rachel to come back to the
Missouri Ozarks, a tainted place that has
caused Rachel an enormous amount of pain.
Now that Ruth is dead, Rachel's plan to work
alongside her is kaput.
She might decide to stay and make more money
than she ever has by working at the casino,
but it also wouldn't be surprising if Rachel
disappeared yet again, out of fear.
Perhaps she, Baby Zeke, and Three will flee
town together?
It's pretty much anyone's guess.
It's also not out of the question that Rachel
might work for the Byrdes.
That prospective work could take place in
Missouri, Chicago, or somewhere else entirely.
This is based solely on speculation since
her storyline ends with her working at the
casino on the night of the Byrde Foundation
gala before Ruth is killed.
The authorities would have to suspect Camila
of killing Ruth, but that's yet another mystery
"Ozark" has left in its wake.
With Ruth's passing, Three is left as the
lone survivor of the Langmore clan.
This is a bit surprising, considering he doesn't
receive as much screen time as many other
Langmore characters and isn't involved in
the cartel or the Snell business.
Nevertheless, Three lives on.
It remains to be seen what the most underrated
Langmore will do now that Ruth is dead.
Ruth presumably left Three with enough resources
to flee the Ozarks and try to find a more
peaceful life someplace else.
But really, you never know.
It's entirely possible that Three will go
after the cartel once he gets a whiff of who
killed his cousin.
We can't say for sure, of course.
Like most of these questions, this will remain
up for debate forever, barring spin-off projects
or particularly revealing interviews with
the creators.
But here's what we do know for certain: Three
witnesses his entire family die while the
Byrde family is in town.
Whether or not those deaths are linked to
that clan, that's the kind of thing that makes
an impression.
For a while, it seemed like the Byrdes might
not make it out of this show alive, or if
they did, they would have sustained irreparable
damage.
After all, Marty has to fill in as the head
of the cartel in Mexico, Wendy checks herself
into a mental health facility in a bid to
get her kids back, and Charlotte and Jonah
are on the verge of leaving with Wendy's father,
Nathan.
"Big decision.
Take some time with it."
But the Byrdes manage to survive separation,
a car crash, and all the other blood-soaked
events that flood the series, and even manage
to create a successful foundation in the process,
thanks to Wendy.
They're now free from the cartel and the FBI.
When we last see the four triumphant family
members, Mel has evidence that will link them
to Ben's death, but then Jonah surprises him
with a shotgun.
Classic Jonah.
This scene, and the entire series, end with
the sound of a gun going off.
Presumably, this comes from Jonah shooting
Mel.
Viewers are faced with a major question: Does
the Byrde family finally go back to Chicago
in the aftermath of this bloodshed?
Someone will have to run the casino after
Ruth's passing, but returning to Chicago was
always the endgame.
Do they fulfill that goal at last?
The Byrdes still have partial ownership of
the casino, and it wouldn't be out of the
question for the cartel to continue laundering
money through it, if they even need to, given
their deal with the FBI.
Though of course, this was always Omar's deal,
and it remains to be seen what Camila plans
on doing as the head of the criminal organization.
Regardless, this deal with the FBI is supposed
to clear the Byrdes of any charges, as well
as settle their debts with the cartel.
They should be clear of criminal activity
from this point on, but since the Byrde Foundation
is still doing business with Clare, who is
doing business with the cartel, who knows
what lines will be crossed?
Will the Byrdes stay clean?
Hopefully, but there's a significant chance
they won't.
The cartel's leader is now free to do basically
whatever she wants, as long as she continues
to cooperate with the FBI.
The series leaves the Byrdes free and clear
from the authorities and the cartel, but they
definitely might not stay that way.
In the final moments of "Ozark," Jonah points
a shotgun at Mel.
The screen goes black, and the sound of a
shot being fired rings out.
This seems pretty definitive, but the ambiguity
of the moment sparks questions.
When shows or movies don't clearly depict
someone's death, it very well might mean they're
not actually dead.
Infamously, "The Sopranos" ends on a similarly
mysterious cut to black, leaving fans to wonder
if Tony Soprano meets his bloody end or not.
"Ozark" is less vague than this ending, though.
While Tony Soprano simply looks up in a diner,
the sound of a gun being fired on "Ozark"
is clear, and Jonah's shotgun is the only
visible weapon in the scene.
It feels pretty safe to say that Jonah kills
Mel.
But since it's not shown, fans might always
wonder what happens and theorize accordingly.
Perhaps, for example, Maya Miller shows up
and fires her gun before Jonah can pull the trigger.
That might seem wild, but it is possible.
More likely than not, Mel meets his demise
at Jonah's hands, and the Byrdes are free
to drive off into the sunset.
It's a perfect ending to a captivating crime
drama full of surprises, but it's not the
only ending fans have to accept.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.